salut il ya quelques jours organisé un
concours pour gagner le film les 7
mercenaires avec denzel washington c'est
un film c'est un remake d'un vieux film
et qui est super sympa un film d'action
et du coup j'avais organisé un concours
pour yannick donc c'était super simple
il fallait aller sur une vidéo
je te mets lien là si tu veux quand même
jeter un coup d'oeil il suffisait
d'aller sur la vidéo de commenter de
licques et partager et puis un tirage au
sort est donc celui qui avait le plus de
chance et celui qui avait le mieux
commenté mieux partagée remporté avec
son dvd en dotation on avait deux blu
ray et un dvd
donc on va faire tout de suite le tirage
au sort parce que concours avait lieu du
1er février au 15 février
donc on y va en fait tirage au sort et
on va voir si tu as gagné allez on se
connecte
là je rentre la dress up je cherche les
commentaires donc samedi qu'il y à 63
commentaires trouvé ce sont trois
commentaires unique
on va tirer le premier pour le le blu
ray ch
le blu-ray tu es pressé partie 3 2 1
bîmes agnès lefebvre toi t'as le blu ray
tu nous as fait un commentaire
trop cool hein mon petit fils je tente
volontiers d'un coup tu as bien fait de
tenter j'ai vérifié
c'était ça a été partagé il ya eu ce
qu'il fallait donc agnès agnès lefebvre
le premier est pour toi un pour agnès
beaucoup de soleil aujourd'hui je sais
pas si ça se boit trop mais lâche t il
ya du soleil a plus le soleil sage et
faire des tout petits yeux c'est hyper
pratique deuxième on va faire pour le
deuxième lot et parce qu'il y avait deux
blu-ray donc c'est parti pour le
deuxième lauréat tension pickeu winner 3
1 go et nous avons christiane du moulin
bonjour super moi qui n'est pas allé au
cinéma avant le film ce serait une belle
occasion pour moi de me rattraper chez
moi avec ce dvd le top merci pour ce jeu
à toi c'est plus le dvd a priori bon je
suis sympa je tenais en dvd ça serait
con que deux films blu ray et co pilote
puisse pas regardé bon les christiane le
dvd il est pour toi un bond du coup on
va retenter pour le bourg et donc il
nous reste le blu ray est parti on y va
à trois 2 1 go
audrey est
est super je participe avec plaisir est
bien cool bravo tu as gagné audrey c'est
pour toi up aujourd'hui que des femmes
à croire qu'ils aient que des femmes qui
regardent cette chaîne audrey donc on a
nos trois gagnantes pour le coup donc
c'est un cru féminin agnès lefebvre et
audrey qui ont gagné les deux blu-ray
chacune leur blu ray et christiane
dumoulin qui repart avec son dvd vous
m'envoyer par message privé directement
vos coordonnées adresse postale pour que
je les transmettent mois à sony et qui
ne sont pas directement par la poste je
vous remercie je vous dis à très bientôt
pour un nouveau concours n'hésitent pas
un site à un moment se regarde cette
vidéo là elle est très sympa tu ta bonne
n'oublie pas je t'aime énormément amuse
toi bien et a très vite ciao